thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys today we have with us
everybody
everybody's here
back on the grave
lady Steve lady Steve was that where
we're calling her we can't call her
ladies he said everyone's here obviously
missing one white guy what kind of grave
were you experiencing I had endo and
kovid obviously remember she told us
about the Indonesia are you here when
she explained that no but I checked on
uh and on her because she had a story
about how she's had the most horrible
time and then I was like how does that
feel and then you're like I've been
having this since I was 15. yeah you're
like oh [__] you're like you're gonna
grow like a third brain I was like I
hope so
she already has two words it's like
having coveted and Ando at the same time
is it like getting coveted and having
morning wood at the same time no well
this is my first time getting covered
experience
um it wasn't
the first
because it's probably not that video
yes not even comparison
um but the first few days body aches
chills were pretty bad but I had friends
who jumped in to help they brought
medicine did you lose taste I uh I took
Ivermectin was that good did it work it
worked you used horse pills
because I I had a flight to see my mom a
week
oh so you're trying to get it over here
yeah yeah so like otherwise I probably
wouldn't have taken it but does it work
though it worked um I think I got side
effects from it meaning like I got like
panic attacks like at night like my
heart was racing super fast
um that's the covet getting but I didn't
have a temperature as far as like you
know going over maybe 99 so I was pretty
normal as far as my 10
body aches chills sucked first few days
um appetite sucked uh damn energy
weakness terrible especially coming
right after Endo was just like I felt
like I was in bed for like a week wow
what was the total length of the
beginning to end of all it
it was like the 30th of last month to
like just before I left to go see my mom
so the seventh wow damn good a good week
and some days yeah the fact that you
just the fact that you just got it is
pretty impressive like you held out this
long I held out for like what three
years where do you think you got it from
do you think you got it from like you
know what I'm saying that's what's crazy
is like I didn't see anybody like
like maybe the gym
somebody didn't wipe their uh probably
gonna be the gym yeah that's gonna be my
my guess did everybody here have covered
already I got one [__] yeah I think it's
because like my you're repping it so
strong it's because my kids I'm a kid
right yeah you have a kid I have a kid
this [__] this homies are making
covet yeah yeah and it doesn't even
affect them you know I mean they're like
I don't know what they're doing licking
handlebars and [__] and then they
[__] bring it back home to all the
parents and all the parents gifts in
China were licking Wuhan bats and [__]
that's how it started that's how it
really started do you think that's true
like because they always say that like
kids always get their parents sick all
the time because they're just getting
sick for some reason they didn't need to
be vaccinated all the kids they were
immune to covet remember when it first
came out they're like oh it's okay
they're not at risk so it's because they
made kovid so since you had tycoats yeah
and he's been going to school more and
like doing more activities you feel like
you get sick way more yeah so I had a a
pretty good like uh regimen I've been
sleeping eight eight hours a day and
then I take my multivitamin and I like
pretty much OD on vitamin C like almost
everything nice and I haven't been sick
for like three years
and then uh the first year Tiger's life
never sick the minute this [__]
goes to school I probably got sick every
other month dude 10 kids out of school
take kids out of school and he doesn't
even really get affected because he's
because he's at a private school he's so
hyper and [__] right that I'm like when
he has a fever I'm like yes chill the
[__] out bro and then this will bounce
it back
[Laughter]
go it was so dope for at least a movie
and a half and I was gone are you in
jail like on the same sick pattern
because of him though do you guys get
like sick at same times
um similarly but she's been getting sick
more than me which is crazy I think her
Mexican teens are wearing off is
Bowl Maybe she's doing more parenting
than you she too
I'm more happy this yeah yeah yeah yeah
something here wait a minute he's like
dude those Mexican jeans are wearing
them that's what it is did you guys get
numb because like on kovid I didn't get
a fever nothing I just lost taste and
then my body got a little numb so I was
like if you did have pains then that
would be the perfect time to get covered
I wish I got that symptom yeah it might
have been nice my skin and everything
the senses were just a little off and it
took about like six months to recover it
whoa so you got like long six months you
got weird covet dude no it was like a
weird lingering like it took about a
little bit over a month to taste again
like normally and then just my sense is
like touch when you jack off it feels
like someone else is doing you oh the
old ghost it felt stranger six minutes
doing anything because it's pretty good
though on both ends it felt like I slept
on my dick huh the dick like you know
what you said tingly feeling yeah yeah
you know when you sleep or like you you
fell asleep don't you hate when that
happens boys oh no my whole body felt
that way oh yeah it was not it was not
normals you probably just need
acupuncture so yeah probably dry
needling
but after after that I was like damn
this is so weird like my whole body I
didn't realize at the time I didn't
realize how numb it was I knew it was
different until I recovered and I was
like oh [__] I could have it was it was
a weird feeling it was like when you did
this with your friend and then someone
hold your hand like that and then like
it didn't feel like your body oh I see
yeah what is that I never did that with
your friend you go like this and then
you hold each side and then you go like
hold on the other side yeah you go like
that like that and you go oh that's
[__] weird bro what is that one dude
Elementary School what do you talk
what's so weird about it I thought you
don't put them together I thought you
tell somebody else to do this and then
you grab it and you hold it yeah what is
that
what is that hold it hold it hold it
like this is it not that and then you
don't feel the hand anymore like you
stop feeling you don't just let you
don't let your homie go I feel Nick I
feel bark and then you squeeze it for
like 30 seconds
like this
no that's what you do yeah draw the line
dude we're not doing it and then you
like this
it's it's when kids are like you want to
feel what a what a dead body feels like
oh okay and then you go like that's a
dead body man kids are dumb dude I think
he grew up with different friends maybe
it's the same game with
different yeah I mean
Duke's a dead body no no so it feels
like a dead body so this right here and
you go oh that's a dead body that's oh
because you can't feel the other side
yeah it's like half dead yeah
[Laughter]
you gotta Channel yourself to being like
12 right
[Laughter]
prerequisite is so big the 12 is too old
you got to be like seven but basically
it's like you could feel this side but
the other feel side feels like flesh so
when you go like everyone at home right
now I get it I get what you say I never
say yeah you guys didn't do that no I
never heard it how about this one did
you do this yeah yeah yeah what do you
think I just see your eyes yeah oh one
once one person's supposed to give you a
club yeah we get both open
you both want to look I was like I see
your eyes
yeah Seven's better oh my God you're
right dude there were so many things
like that though when you were a kid
there were so many like weird little
there weren't cell phones that's true
huh we did [__] we came up with stuff
right so there's nothing remember when
you had [__] pieces of yarn and [__]
you would walk up to like [__] people
at school
look the Batmobile today's video is
brought to you by Sunday Springtime is
here that means the grass is gonna grow
flowers gonna Bloom oh my goodness I
want a beautiful lawn but every single
time I go into the store I just feel so
confused I don't know what to do which
fertilizer do I get I have no idea man
but thanks to Sunday they got us covered
no trips to the store or hauling heavy
bags since they ship straight to your
home you just need a hose to apply
Sunday you can fertilize your whole lawn
in less time that it takes to watch your
favorite TV show this spring go to
sunday.com off the Record and enter your
address to get a customized plan created
just for your lawn check this out this
one baby right here is probably good for
West coasters and Californians like us
that go through extreme drought
conditions and this one
every lawn type and Sunday is offering
our listeners 20 Off full season plans
start just at a hundred and nine dollars
and you can get 20 off when you visit
getsunday.com off the Record at checkout
that's 20 your custom plan at
getsunday.com off the Record freaking
loser you guys do the origami with the
numbers yeah dude yeah give me one
through four one two three four or
they're all bad you're right all like
yeah
you remember remember that that sounds
so familiar it was like it was like yeah
and it was like man what does it stand
for oh Mansion apartment Shack house
yeah and it was like it was like a game
where you put like four choices of each
category or something I don't know but
it would be like it would be kind of
like this [__] thing where at the end
you'd be like you're gonna live in a
mansion you're gonna marry Jennifer
yeah yeah you're gonna be yeah something
like that I'm gonna be a [__] and you're
gonna be a hoe yeah yeah yeah
15 years later yeah I think so I think
so your crush is in there both of those
things is just to get your crush really
and you just keep doing it yeah it's
gonna happen
but the funny thing is now people I
think kids still have things like this
except now it's just made for Content or
it's on Tick Tock where kids are dancing
it's just a different version of it it's
like they still do these things but then
it's if you can't film it then they
probably don't even do it oh so we're
just making content back in the day
we're just from filming yeah or there's
just a different form like we did
Blackout Challenge we just weren't
filming it yeah luckily yeah a lot of
those things were invented
Blackout Challenge when you were no what
kind of stuff did you do as a kid
we did cops and robbers we did what did
you like to play I like a little biking
you had a bike game yeah brother and I
like would like ride our bikes around
three ninja style silver trash cans uh
no we're not you know put dynamite in
mailboxes but we did like
where did we get that we did uh sneak
into like people's backyards and like
jump over the fences and stuff and what
would you do once you got back there
turn on the propane on the grill
[Music]
you know sneak into stuff and just be a
kid use your imagination but I do
remember one time I hopped over fence
and like my pants got caught and started
to rip my brother just took off he's
like sorry fend for yourself yeah pretty
much
for a moment it's funny to do
inconvenient things to like because
we're so uncreative as kids you just go
to houses to turn the hose on in the
front and just walk away like like dumb
[__] that's like it's just
yeah vandalism yeah I didn't know
how to do stuff do you ever get caught
when you were doing stuff like that
um
once my uh that damn line
kid with endometriosis
growing brains on her ulcer my bedroom
had a patio that could like Overlook my
neighbor's yard and we hated my
neighbors they were such [__] and so
like there was these like little pile
rocks not the ones that I walked dirty
ones
they're little small ones and for some
reason we just started throwing the
rocks at their house for some reason I
love that same style we just were like
yeah these rocks and it was kind of like
whoever gets caught loses and the guy
comes out of the house screaming like
hey quit throwing rocks at my house like
we have the rocks in our hands like
we're not throwing rocks
I remember my mom coming upstairs being
like you guys were so good today you
were quiet while we were working we're
gonna go get ice cream and we're like
she doesn't find out no we did not I
hope she doesn't find out about these uh
Rock throwing at our neighbors maybe she
would have been like cool they're
[__] yeah that was pretty tired of
UK
neighbor to reciprocate because I
remember I had my neighbor right next to
us with a chucking rocks back at your
house they were so cool because like you
know like sometimes you um like let's
say your ball gets into someone's yard
and you go like this and you go ding
dong like oh my ball went into your can
I have a cereal or ma'am or whatever
in your mind you're like [__] you [__]
it's a Sandlot guy yeah yeah but when
your neighbor is like oh yeah sure hey
next time it comes over just hop the
fence just grab it you immediately form
like an alliance yeah and then now I'm
like I'm gonna protect your yard too
yeah yeah our neighbors didn't like us
we have peacocks and they were loud you
guys have peacocks yeah at your house
yeah we have peacocks as pets oh no my
dad just brought one home one day I was
just like here we go it's so fun you're
like peacocks yeah it was it was fun
until they're like screeching oh we had
to get loud huh dookies are [__] like
cats eyes yeah well we got three of them
we had two males and one female and they
were more pets you know they roam around
Arcadia like just on the streets and
[__]
because there's an Atrium close spot no
like there they let them out during the
day
they go back and then they're they're
like sleeping in the atrium and [__] oh
that's tight everyone here run them over
they're they're protecting no everyone
nobody likes her nobody likes some
arcade I heard like they see themselves
in the car and they think it's like a
rival and then they [__] hit the car
and then people's cars get all Dental oh
my God scream at you they'll Punk your
dogs and [__] yeah they're pretty
they're kind of a nuisance they're a
pain in the ass too like any animal
that's protected ends up thinking it's
the [__] and they're the coolest so
protected it has no bullies that's why
animals should have some bullies like
coyotes coyotes
who should bully a peacock Joe I'd kick
them in the chest
human human Asians yeah kick them in the
net dude I'm against animal abuse but
something about birds makes me want to
kick off wobbles kick a bird you know
what's another really strange uh prank
this is so weird that I remembered this
you during Christmas time people have
like wreaths on their door you know some
of those wreaths sometimes people had
like Christmas bells like as a
decoration you take the Bell off and
then you you uh tie it underneath their
car
so then all year
and they're just like
oh my God it's such a stupid thing to do
you might be the master of pranks dog
you're doing you're calling out [__]
that
I ever thought of doing that and when
you think about it it's true it's like
the boredom of being a kid and not
having anything to do like we just did
the ketchup packets you didn't do that
what's that you get ketchup and you kind
of twist it right oh yeah it's about to
burst and you put it like behind the
Cars and when they when they like later
when they get out of the car like what
is that
and they're like
that's a presentation of an adult you
can't even be himself he's Mr Wilson you
think it's blood remember the thing I
told you in Cerritos Town Center they
had a lot of loose uh you know the
reflector on the ground between the lane
it's like yellow they would be loose for
some reason and then you could flip them
over as soon as you choose you flip them
over and you put it in the middle of the
road and when cars run it over it goes
and it flies off yeah it like becomes
like a saw blade
That's so exciting we used to have a
lemon fights between me and my neighbors
because like um the way that all of our
backyards it was connected by one uh
fence right [__] love them so then
yeah the big fan of 11. we all had like
different lemon trees and [__] and then
when it's growing those things [__]
grow and I forgot how it started but it
became a thing where if I hear him in
the backyard like I chucked lemons and
they chucked lemons and we would just
start launching and then I feel like
they invited friends and then like I
started inviting friends and it would
just be like five on five kids just
chucking lemons and then just trying to
get them over the head like it was so
fun it's coming over yeah it was like
lemons
pick them up Chuck them get new ones you
guys got Shields and [__] dude it was
yeah we didn't do that but we played
baseball with lemons and that's not such
fun memories lemons are always
it's mainly that and then how do we
pretend like lemons just naturally
explode when the parents come and ask
what the [__]
40 yeah I was trying to think of The
Alibi or the reasoning behind what
you're doing yo you know what I don't
see anymore is like like 10 kids on
bicycles like riding down the street
going to the liquor store I know that's
me that was me yeah I think everyone did
that I think they get like abducted and
stuff now and it's like caught on camera
and then there's it's on the news and
then nobody's neighborhood's like in the
Deep suburbs do they do that you see
yeah
why are you Whispering that because yeah
right because I've been telling you
there's places
these days like the way that we were
different kids
yeah AI kids I hope so oh yeah yeah
there's [__] dicks still like I'll be
at the park and there's like the 13 year
old that's like oh look I can climb on
top of the [__] the top of the Jungle
Gym you know and he's sitting on top
you're so [__] whack I wish I was 13
just go then kick your ass right now
if I was 13 I'd kick your [__] ass
dude you show off all right though there
was always that kid though right the
show-off yeah doing too much yeah cause
everyone's just playing and then there's
the kid that's like a little bit older
he has better capabilities he's like
yeah look at me everybody can you guys
get up here I'm like man and he's like
the Dork where kids are his age like
he's the Dork there so that he got hella
flips on those monkey bars that's true
the older kid you're always like oh he's
so cool and then like you realize that
guy was actually a nerd yeah he's not
cool yeah he's like over there trying to
impress kids yeah yeah
I'm gonna go to a playground today and
I'm just gonna press some kids Maybe not
maybe not now I remember him
oh yeah you're right
check it out kids Brown
second dime
I can climb to the top of the Jungle Gym
the kid's like well I got a black
oh [__] how'd you get that man who's
your son say
[Music]